welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navarro and today I'm telling you
everything you need to know about a
comic book character who may be the
inspiration for the bad guy in the
upcoming MCU movie the Marvels Dar Ben
is a Cree Warrior revolutionary played
by zowie Ashton but no one knows who the
heck she is or anything the heck about
her comic book iteration but that's
where I come in I'm gonna tell you
literally everything there is to know
about this Marvel Comics character and
you're gonna tell me if you enjoyed me
talking to you or not so let's get into
it firstly Dar Ben of Earth 616 in the
comics is a male character not a woman
but it looks like that's thankfully been
updated for the Marvels is to better
reflect their real world ratios between
men and women and not deliver us yet
another male villain character which the
MCU is always going to have an abundance
of next Dar ban was created by Ron Mars
and Ron Lim were the writer and penciler
behind Silver Surfer number 53 from 1991
where Dar Ben first appeared he was a
Cree General who was extremely patriotic
and conspired with other loyal Cree
generals to publicly assassinate the
puppet Cree Emperor clumsy Fowler who to
be fair was a cartoonishly corrupt idiot
the cree generals also planned to kill
the traitorous Cree who kept Emperor
foul up on the throne a Cree General
named DUI Zan this was also during a
really precarious time in Cree history
in the comics right after Thanos had
used The Infinity Gauntlet to wipe out
half of all life in the universe this is
why Silver Surfer 53 was an Infinity
Gauntlet crossover General Dar Ben's
plan as a pink Cree which means that he
had human skin tone was to seize power
after their planned assassination with
fellow Cree General Isle Dan a blue
Creed which means he had a blue skin
tone so that there would be no racial
conflict between the two classes of Cree
people but because either he or ale Dan
couldn't be the one to deliver the
killing blow because of the potential
rejection by the other Cree peoples they
hired the Silver Surfer to be the one to
do it but what the surfer didn't know is
that the cree planned to destroy him
afterwards the the next day Emperor
foulup was delivering an empire-wide
transmission when the Silver Surfer
arrived blasting through various Cree
security guards sorry guards y'all got
surfed then the surfer made it to the
emperor but General duisan stood in his
way until the Silver Surfer Silver
smoked him the entire time the surfer
was lying and saying he was sent there
by the scroll Empire so that the cree
people watching live wouldn't know that
fellow Crees planned the whole
assassination after the Silver Surfer
positively melted clumsy foul up our two
hero Cree generals arrived on the scene
darben and Ale Dan these two Cree
generals declare war on the Scrolls and
fight off the Silver Surfer with their
pretty impressive Weaponry then the
impossible seemingly happens the Silver
Surfer gets vaporized this was part of
that plan after all so that Dar Ben and
his Cree co-conspirators leave no loose
ends that could implicate them in the
assassination they declared to the cree
Empire that they'll take over leadership
and then end the live feed then they
gather up the surfer's remains take it
down to base basement level 10 in that
very same building where they meet
another co-conspirator Dr k r Lin who's
a scientist that constructed and
programmed a Silver Surfer robot to do
their bidding what a twist it was a
Silver Surfer robot the whole time then
the cree generals kill the scientists
who built the robot to ensure no Loose
Ends
so we won't actually see Dar Ben for a
while but he will be leading the creep
people along with his blue Cree partner
in crime in the background of Marvel
comic stories
one shot energy huh okay I'll try it
[Applause]
whoa what is one shots Focus chew do
[Music]
whoa one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 10
off your order as we move into the next
Cosmic crossover storyline operation
Galactic storm the cree Supreme
intelligence begins to use his powers to
manipulate the leaders of three major
Interstellar Empires the cree the
skrulls and the shiar those are the bird
people usually associated with X-Men
stories this big floating green head
implants the idea of creating a mega
bomb so massive it could wipe out a
large enough Interstellar empire into
the minds of the leadership of the Shia
and then mentally intensifies the
prejudices of each of the Empire's
leadership to the point that the cree
the Scrolls and the Shia all declare war
on each other the cree leadership
Emperors darben and ayldan along with
Shia magistrix lelandra are manipulated
into a race to collect the components
needed to actually make this bomb and
the Shia eventually get one of the
pieces needed the deceased Cree
superhero Captain Marvel's Nega bands
which allowed him to switch places
across space with human Rick Jones so
then in 1992's Avengers number 346 where
the militaristic cree were now at war
with the matriarchal Shia The Avengers
went to the heart of the cree Empire
Capital planet krilar to try and prevent
this Galactic war from consuming
everything this lineup included Captain
America Steve Rogers Hercules son of
Zeus Crystal of the Inhumans Black
Knight Dane Whitman and Cersei of the
eternals Elsewhere on creelar we catch
up to our cree co-emperers eldan and dar
Ben who have upgraded from basic Cree
General uniforms to Lavish attire that
befits those who would lead as two kings
they're just chewing out Supreme accuser
Ronan and then we learn that shiar agent
the Mad death bird and sister till
Alandra has arrived on the planet then
the cree Supreme intelligence who has
been observing all the major moment so
far unveils his elite team of Cree
Warriors Star Force that includes Cree
Fighters like Captain Atlas Dr Minerva
and korath the pursuer the Supreme
intelligence lies to Star Force and says
the Avengers are there to assassinate
the two Cree Emperors so the Avengers
with Cersei and Crystal rocking those
sweet bulky 90s jackets fight off Star
Force and it's just fun to remember that
there are two Marvel characters present
who have both been played by Gemma Chan
when suddenly in the midst of heated
battle sons of Pama guardians of sacred
Hala commanders Supreme of the Imperial
Cree Empire darben and eldan arrive on
the scene they question the Avengers and
even questions Star Force not
recognizing all of those Cree Warriors
and sentenced them as well to death just
because of the emperor's perceived lack
of security but before that can be
carried out the Mad death bird late
magistricts of the hated shiar shows up
in straight murders aeel Dan then turns
her attention to DAR Ben who faces his
fate as a crease Soldier and spits on
all things she are well my dude
shouldn't have done that because with a
chunk death bird stabs darben right in
the onomatopoeia and our Cree character
dies with empty boasts on Trembling Lips
after that the scheming Supreme
intelligence takes over for leadership
of the cree and Riles up his people to
want revenge on the Shia for their
assassination of the former Emperors a
life for a life it is the cree way after
all something we see after is that the
minds of darben and Eldon were absorbed
into the cree Supreme intelligence so
that's morbid and gross if you want to
see how this all plays out check out the
comic book storyline operation Galactic
storm but yeah that's pretty much the
end of darben and there you have it
folks the entire Comics history of Dar
Ben from his first appearance where he
was fated to rule to his second
appearance where he was fated to die
will these stories Inspire this new
villain of the Marvels that's up to you
to speculate thanks for letting me talk
about comics for you follow me over on
Heroes Reef forged on YouTube and we'll
see you next time bye
[Music]